this is how the virus first reached
sub-saharan Africa the first confirmed
case here in Lagos authorities are
checking people as they arrived but it
can be a while before an infection makes
someone feel ill enough to seek help so
the gentleman who came here apparently
may have gotten infected if I both
walked through these scenes a screening
with no symptoms and by the time he got
to his house I think a day or two after
he started to feel unwell and wisely
enough he went to a hospital
Nigeria's for functioning international
airports our focus now for intensified
checks but the virus has landed and
people are concerned if a country like
China unlocks totally
balancing sophisticated as yeah very bad
idea
I'm very still and I just hope that the
government will act very very fast up
front about this and make sure that the
citizens are safe I'm really really
scared that we have to allow this to get
to us we have ample time to prevent it
fortunately scared us let me start
religiously free that
[Music]
spreading the word we'll take a joint
effort the Health Minister said would
you believe that religious leaders
traditional leaders community
gatekeepers they are listening to what
we are saying because I say leader
definitely you don't want your people to
get sick and if you hear of this kind of
advisory I'm sure they all call their
condition and advise them to follow the
guidelines that are being given for now
officials are trying to trace all those
who were on the infected man's flight
I'm joined now by DW reporter wasted
race who was at the press conference
with Nigerian health minister on Friday
hello always nice to have you now how
are thority trying to treat all those
this Italian could have come into
contact with
well what the Minister of Health in
Nigeria said and the authorities are
doing are trying to track all the people
that might have traveled with this
Italian person and then the people he
might have come in contact with because
he went to his house it was two days
after arriving in Nigeria that he
reported back to the hospital so there I
showed Nigerians that they are going to
track them and will be kept for 14 to 28
days to ensure that they don't have the
virus and if they show any sign then
they will be taken to the treatment
center which is okay separated from
other hospital facilities okay I mean it
sounds like definitely difficult to do
so I'm sure you're working out the best
strategies but talking about strategies
the Health Ministry has been given some
sort of guidelines for people to use to
help contain the virus what are some of
those guidelines they are spreading
around well number one they said anybody
that has a sign of cold or flu shall
please immediately report himself to a
health facility and will be treated free
of charge and then people should avoid
living in congested area people should
start using hand sanitizers and they are
going to use the traditional rulers as
religious leaders does the way Nigeria
did when it had Ebola because you know
churches are Moxie's are places where
you had a lot of congregation a lot of
conjunction of people okay thanks for
the update there DW reporter who is
address thank you